we are here to build TAC support the
civilian population that end you must
avoid killing it at all costs
we can't help them and kill them at the
same time it's just a humanly possible
this Wars been running eight years man
given your reputation and your from
middle ground
our hope is that you're the man who will
get the job done
most of us here will know general
McMahon's the man who take down Haider
in attack your walls are your troops in
workers moving in a little bit show
everyone a nice looking set of graphs
just finished respect the law school you
can stay in Afghanistan forever
that's why I'm gonna win it my team and
I are about to embark on a new direction
what is this mutilation we build
Afghanistan into a free and prosperous
nation or smile for the camera
sounds a lot like the old direction I
come here manage this war and I sure as
[ __ ] didn't come here to close it out
it's my job to ensure that your personal
ambitions are kept in check think of me
that we are here without God's trying to
convince these people really nice guy
and he sees weapons in corrected
you're not here to win you're here to
clean up the mess for the plans we are
change
you
[Music]
you